we have a trailer to Indy five
which means numerically that means nd4
still happens [ __ ] don't get me wrong I
do enjoy Indie 4's disc to use as a
coaster while I'm watching the Indiana
Jones trilogy but now we have a trailer
for Indiana Jones 5 Indiana Jones and
the dial of Fate I think it is the dial
of Destiny a little different but I was
I was there ish Indiana Jones returns I
believe the year it's 1969 mads
Mickelson plays the Baddie which I'm
loving I enjoy seeing John Reese Davey's
back and he's like oh I missed the good
old times you know the excitement Indy's
like those days are long over that's the
best I got for Indiana Jones
impersonation but they're only over
until they're not and I can't help but
be nervous or concerned well I can't
help but be nervous or concerned because
I was there looking forward to Kingdom
of the Crystal Skull then I was there
after I watched Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull but my favorite actions sequences
among indie films are practical the boat
chase sequence boat getting chewed up by
the propeller this movie a lot of CGI
action sequences and an execution might
look fantastic might feel fantastic it
might be at the edge of my seat the
entire time but the thing or person that
has me going Yep this is worth doing a
video on I'm actually looking forward to
a new indie movie well first of all when
that music comes on you can't help but
get excited
[Music]
name of the Crystal Skull trailer had it
too and it worked for me then too but
director James mangled he's been on a
run man so I can't help but be like oh
he's directing
all right cool it does crack me up in
here but he's like I don't believe in
magic I'm like oh yeah why would you
believe in magic granted the very next
line is like
I've seen some [ __ ] been paraphrasing he
says something along those lines look
all I'm saying is you haven't just seen
some things that got you thinking well
maybe sometimes impossible-ish things
might happen no you have straight up
seen magic and I know you believe in
magic because in writers of the Lost Ark
you told Marion to keep her eyes shut
why because you believe that if you
watched what was going down your faces
were gonna melt or your heads were gonna
explode or you'd be sucked into the ark
to be lost forever sorry to tell you
Indy that was you believing in Magic and
if that wasn't enough I don't care who
you are the fact that the Holy Grail
saved your father's life maybe you'd be
like that might have been baking soda
and vinegar but the moment you crawled
out of that nuke fridge unscathed you
should have been like
so Magic's real that should have come
out looking like a pizza topping out of
that thing but yeah Indiana Jones and
the dial of Destiny doesn't matter what
Crystal Skull did it's a new indie movie
I can't help but be like Harrison Ford's
still going at it there was a time I was
thinking to recapture the magic of
Indiana Jones you don't bring old
Indiana Jones back for a new Indiana
Jones movie you make an Uncharted movie
then they made an Uncharted movie and
I'm like okay what's old Indy got let's
do it old I'm calling them old over here
I'm calling them old full well knowing
he could beat my ass so whatever all
right so the trailer for Indiana Jones
and the dial of Destiny are you looking
forward to the movie did Indiana Jones
and the kingdom of the Crystal Skull
make you like
the no whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]